and this is not good for vulnerable
viewers and it's definitely not good for
her you know I lived in a body that was
taken over by any
and so I know how I interpreted positive
reinforcement the likes the followers
even the comments expressing obvious
concern all of those can be equated with
success that the smaller my body the
further I push the more love and
attention I receive so Eugenia I just
want to say
that I'm really really sorry I'm sorry
that all of us watching around the world
and even in your own home like the
person behind the camera who's supposed
to love and protect you
we've all let you down so to anyone
watching my video Even if you are
eugenia's number one fan
help her by reporting her content and I
say this with absolute love and concern
for her